so help me if three billboards outside
Epping Missouri wins best picture over
this and get out I'm I don't know I'm
out complaining I suppose the shape of
water the latest film by Guillermo del
Toro currently nominated for a whole
bunch of Oscars including Best Picture
Best Director Best Actress Best
Supporting Actress Best Supporting Actor
and having now seen it deserving each
and every one of those nominations I
thought this movie was absolutely
phenomenal I thought it was beautiful
and touching and poetic and just
gorgeous
I mean visually gorgeous I you should
expect that from a yellow del Toro movie
but emotionally gorgeous as well if this
was just a masterfully put together film
I did I don't know if I'm prepared to
say this definitively but it might be my
favorite guillermo del toro film that's
not me saying it's his best film I do
make a distinction between personal
favorite and best I think certainly
Pan's Labyrinth is the purest
representation of him and his mindset
and the things that intrigue him put on
film but I think for me this this might
be this might be my favorite thing he's
ever done so I I'm not gonna get into
spoilers on this cuz I know it's it's
only started to get beyond limited
release so I know that this is pretty
good chance a lot of people haven't seen
it but things like is a flea tell you
about the premise it's a period piece
set in the 50s in the US and it deals
with this woman who is mute she's not
deaf she's mute and she is a cleaner at
a government facility and she's been
there a while and they just they do
research on various things and
Jeanette's played by sally hawkins and
she has a friend at work played by
Octavia Spencer she has a neighbor of
doubt who lives down the hall from her
from her apartment played by Richard
Jenkins who's basically though these are
her two friends in the world and they
bring in what they call
a new asset into the facility which is
effectively a modern update of the gill
man from Creature from the Black Lagoon
that's pretty much what it is played by
the always amazing Doug Jones I mean
there was a reason that they put him and
basically any creature that is not
supposed to be big and muscular
basically always gets played by Doug
Jones because he's really good at this
sort of stuff and it's a it's a gorgeous
stunning design on the on the creature I
mean that's not a spoiler to get into
but it really is it's beautiful and then
it just follows the bond that forms
between this woman who can't speak and
this creature that most of the people in
the facility do not regard as human and
there is naturally there's an
antagonistic character the head of
security played by Michael Shannon there
is one of the scientists on site who
kind of has an interesting role to play
in all this and and actually I really
like his story and and how that all pans
out I can't go into more than that
without getting to spoilers for stuff
that happens later on but I really I
really loved his story and I loved his
angle and it is just the bonding of
those two characters and then the
consequences that happen as a result of
that and it is it really is beautiful
there's a very for lack of a better term
there's a very French vibe to it I think
part of it is the way the camera moves I
think part of it's the music choice but
it has that sort of slow pan from
tableau to tableau life let's linger on
this image let's let this you know this
you know sort of European II period
music play and it's very it's very
deliberate it's it's not I don't think
it's slow but it takes its time it lets
moments settle
which i think is a big part of why it I
found it to be as powerful as it is and
all the performances are great you know
Octavia Spencer is basically Octavia
Spencer she plays what she pretty much
always plays and you know you get what
it says on the box but she's really good
in this part she's a good to good fit
for it she works really well she's got
great chemistry with sally hawkins sally
hawkins i don't know her from anything
else or if i have seen or anything else
i've never noticed her before she's
amazing because what she has to convey
as an actress without the benefit of her
voice and how effortlessly she does it
how well we as the audience can see her
thought process and understand her
emotions with little words sent by her
it's an amazing amazing performance and
Richard Jenkins since I first saw him
and six feet under and he is wonderful
and warm and loving and again another
great wonderful friend character some of
the other things that like how well this
movie works again it's hard for me too
I got a talk in vagaries here but
there's two scenes that happen one about
3/4 of the way in and one towards the
very end that on paper should have lost
me should have completely lost me these
moments but they didn't and I and I was
sitting even as I was watching it and
buying it and like yes and something in
the back of my brain was going
I shouldn't be buying into this but I
don't care and like that again just
speaks to the strength of the execution
of this movie it's not perfect there is
basically one weak link in this and that
is Michael Shannon not his portrayal of
the character he's actually very well
cast for the type of role he's playing
he's a good fit he plays the part well
it's more to do with we get
we get extra time with him as a
character that I don't think benefits
anything because pretty much as soon as
he shows up you get that he is he's
gonna be the problem he's he is
effectively the bad guy for this story
we get these extra scenes of like him at
a car dealership him with his family and
with his wife and normally I would say
if you're gonna have those extra scenes
they should be giving more depth to the
character so buddy understand them
better and maybe that was the idea but
the thing is I would argue that the
things that we learn about this
character through those additional
scenes actually aren't new all it really
does is reinforce the stuff that we can
basically just assume from the way he
act so these extra scenes don't give us
new insight they just give an
explanation for what was already very
obvious on the surface and I think for
what we get out of that it was time that
didn't need to be spent on him I'd say
there's probably between five and ten
minutes that can just be dropped from
the movie just by dropping these
extraneous scenes cuz his performance is
good enough that you get you get this
guy pretty much immediately and the
extra scenes don't add much that is I
think literally my only complaint about
this movie it and I really do want to
emphasize this is touching to me I did I
I cried I cried at two points in this
movie and I'll tell you about one of
those points because I mean they I can
talk about this without it getting too
much into spoilers because it was about
halfway into the movie and obviously
sally hawkins develops a pretty strong
bond with this fish man and she is
explaining through sign to richard
jenkins why you know what is the root of
this bond and what she says to him
is when he looks at me
he doesn't know that I can't speak he
doesn't know that I am incomplete he
only sees me and not what I'm missing
and there's that and there's and there's
another one she has a like maybe only 30
seconds later that was also a beautiful
line but that the strength of that
connection and ultimately I think that's
that's why I keep coming back to this is
a beautiful movie and not just visually
because I think it really it speaks to
people who go through a good chunk of
their lives and there's something about
them that either they themselves or
their family or society in general would
deem as wrong as a defect and usually
when when something like that is an
apparent thing it's it's something that
you always feel like it's the first
thing people see about you so she and
that moment do such a wonderful job of
conveying the strength of feeling when
you encounter somebody who doesn't see
that defect who either doesn't see it at
all or doesn't see it as a problem and I
think it has its it has a really
powerful message that I can speak to any
number of people whether it be people
who are physically disabled people who
you know are are part of the LGBTQ
community people who just feel like
there's something wrong with me no one
will ever get me her power and the
emotionality of her performance
throughout the movie but especially in
that moment encapsulate the power of
finding someone who gets you when you
literally did not believe that such a
thing was possible and it is beautiful
and it's not just a beautiful moment it
holds throughout the film
I like I said I do think this is my
favorite gamma del Toro movie I was
enraptured I was moved I was stunned I
sat through the credits not because I
expected there to be some kind of bonus
scene or anything at the end but because
I didn't I didn't want to leave I did I
did not want the lights to come up I
didn't want the experience to be over
and I have a feeling that when the end
of the year comes around I might cheat
and put this on my consideration for
best movies of 2018 yes I know it came
out in in 2017 but it came out at the
end of December it was in limited
release so the only people who saw it in
December were professional critics and
people who live in New York and LA for
everybody else for all intensive
purposes this is a 2018 movie this I'm
gonna have to recognize this thing again
it when the end of the year comes around
and if I don't then it is been an
astonishing year at the movies so the
shape of water those are my thoughts I
love this absolutely love it have you
seen it what do you think about it if
you haven't seen it what's your favorite
guillermo del toro movie and why
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all the stuff you know
the likes and subscribes and Twitter
follows and patreon support maybe hey
it's an option all that stuff that's got
links down below so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]